>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Ladies and gentleman acting
Librarian of Congress David Mao.
[ Applause ]
>> Mr. Blair, members of Congress,
distinguished guests good evening.
We are deeply honored to
welcome to the Library
of Congress tonight the right
Honorable Tony Blair, Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom
and Great Britain
and Northern Ireland
from 1997 to 2007.
We are right now in the great Hall
of the Thomas Jefferson building,
the historic Thomas Jefferson
building of the Library of Congress
and as you can see we
are surrounded by artwork
that symbolizes the progress of
civilization and the traditions
of knowledge and learning so I think
it's a very, very fitting venue
for us tonight to have the
seventh Kissinger lecture.
Mr. Blair will be speaking
in conversation
with Ambassador Martin Indyk.
The Kissinger lecture was
established during the library's
bicentennial year in
2000 and the purpose was
to foster nonpartisan
foreign policy discussion
in this our nation's capital.
The lecture has been
delivered by former president
of Mexico Felipe Calderon,
former president
of Brazil Fernando Henrique
Cardoso, former president
of the French Republic [inaudible],
as well as the former United States
secretaries of State James Baker,
George Schultz and
Mr. Kissinger himself.
Tonight's speaker, Mr.
Tony Blair, is a statesman
with deep democratic values
and a positive vision
for the world's future.
He's built bridges among cultures
and people around the world
and during his tenure
expanded access to education
and health care throughout
his country.
Mr. Blair we admire you
very much for your courage
in championing security,
democracy and the rule of law.
Your leadership developed
unprecedented levels of cooperation
between your country and ours
and although you are retired
from public office you
continue to commit yourself
to building a better world
for future generations to work
with numerous foundations and
leadership councils so ladies
and gentlemen please join me
in welcoming a great
statesman, Mr. Tony Blair.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much indeed
David and ladies and gentlemen.
It's a great honor to be giving
the Kissinger lecture this evening
in this wonderful [inaudible]
building.
Henry Kissinger was always a great
foreign-policy role model of mine
and he is now actually
a role model of mine
for the aging process [laughter].
I always say to him if I manage to
get to his age I'll have done well
but if I get to his age with
even a quarter of his intellect
and brilliance I will
be truly blessed.
I once actually asked Henry what's
it like being Henry Kissinger?
And he said to me well you know
he said a few months back I was
at a party and a woman came
up to me and she said -
Dr. Henry Kissinger, people will
tell me you are so fascinating,
so fascinate me [laughter].
He said that's what
it's like [laughter].
I said it could be worse [laughter].
So tonight I'm going to
give a 20-minute lecture.
The subject is around Islamic
extremism which is certainly for us
in Europe today the topic of
the day and then I'm going to be
in conversation with Martin Indyk
who I'm delighted has kindly agreed
to do the interview and
question/answer session
of this talk this evening, and
because obviously the time for me
to speak is limited I'm actually
publishing tomorrow morning a longer
essay, an 8000 word essay on this
topic and what I think we should do
about it so tonight of necessity
what you will get is the outline
and the general points but if you
want greater detail you will see
this set out in the essay tomorrow.
To defeat Islamic extremism we need
a strategy that is comprehensive.
Defeating Daesh or ISIS is
only a necessary beginning
and force alone will not prevail.
The challenge goes far wider
and deeper than the atrocities
of the jihadist fanatics.
The Islamist ideology has
also to be confronted.
Today it can be in alliance with
the modernizing and sensible voices
within Islam determined to take the
name and reputation of the faith
of Islam back from extremists,
but a continued failure
to recognize the scale
of the challenge
and to construct the means
necessary to meet it will result
in terrorist attacks
potentially worse than those
in Paris producing a backlash
which then stigmatizes the majority
of decent law-abiding Muslims and
puts the very alliance that is
so necessary at risk creating a
further cycle of chaos and violence.
9/11 came out of the
Al Qaeda training camps
of Afghanistan permitted to
grow there by the Taliban
but today Daesh controls
an area of land in Syria
and Iraq roughly the size of the UK.
It has a significant
presence in Libya around Sert.
It is a foothold in the Sinai
and in several other areas.
It has the allegiance of Boko
Haram in Nigeria as well as groups
in other parts of sub-Saharan
Africa, but you can add
to Daesh [inaudible] and half
a dozen other such groups
and they are all active, trained,
battle hardened reasonably
well armed and funded
and in many cases they are
on the doorstep of Europe.
It is true that our security
services are vastly more equipped
and experienced in dealing
with the threat than in 2001
but this is also true of the enemy.
They now know that a
handful of gunmen prepared
to kill totally innocent and random
people can traumatize a nation.
Does anyone doubt that if they could
kill thousands not hundreds they
would or that they would use any
means available to them to do it.
The impact of terrorism
is never simply
about the tragedy of the lives lost.
It is the sense of
instability, insecurity
and fear that comes in its wake.
It can paralyze the country and
in the case of nations like ours
with our proud and noble
traditions of tolerance
and liberty it makes those very
strengths seem like weaknesses
in the face of an onslaught that
cares nothing for our values
and hates our way of life.
Europe is facing this
dilemma in a very direct way.
It is with courage and compassion
bringing large numbers of refugees
from the carnage of Syria and the
wider Middle East into Europe.
Greece alone has around 700,000
refugees awaiting clearance.
The other week the Prime Minister
told me it had 15,000 people enter
Greece in the space of 12 hours.
We need to prepare host
communities and incoming refugees
for what will be an
extraordinary undertaking.
Of course it would be
inhumane to refuse entry
but I'm not sure we fully comprehend
the size of this challenge.
So what are the pillars of
such a comprehensive strategy?
First the immediate task is
of course to defeat Daesh.
Paris has galvanized
opinion but we need
to understand the full nature
of what has to be done.
They have to be eliminated on the
ground not just in Syria and Iraq
but in Libya too and the other
countries in which they are present.
Together with our allies we have
to do what it takes to defeat them
and defeat them completely.
This will require a
combination of military,
diplomatic and political measures.
Now this does not always have to
center on our boots on the ground.
Our forces can play a
supporting role to others
but destroying the so-called
caliphate is an essential part
of destroying the concept of
it as a unifying structure
for extremist groups which underpin
so much of the jihadist propaganda.
It is also essential to securing a
just outcome in Syria which in turn
of course is the only
solution to the refugee crisis.
To begin with many in the West
thought Syria was a nightmare
but not our nightmare.
Now we know we're in
it like it or not.
We must show sufficient commitment
to Syria to give us the leverage
to be able to negotiate a settlement
which will allow the country
over time to progress
with full respect
from minorities but without Assad.
Second then in the
medium term we have
to construct the force capability
internationally through a coalition
of nations willing to commit their
armed forces which would allow us
to fight the jihadist extremists
effectively wherever they try
to gain a foothold.
They must know that they are
never safe to plan or to expand.
And further and longer
term and most important,
the subject of my talk
tonight, we must realize
that the problem is not only the
violence of groups like Daesh
but the ideology of
extremism behind them.
It is correct that the number
of jihadist fanatics is relatively
small but the numbers who buy
into significant parts of
their underlying worldview are
unfortunately much larger.
Islam is practiced and understood
by the large majority of believers
as a peaceful and honorable faith.
It has contributed greatly to human
existence and progress but there has
to be an end to the denial about
the nature of the problem we face.
Of course a large majority
of Muslims completely
reject Daesh-like jihadism
and the terrorism that
comes with it,
however in many Muslim countries
large numbers also believe
that the CIA or Jews
were behind 9/11.
Clerics who proclaimed
the nonbelievers
and [inaudible] must be
killed or who call for jihad
against Jews have twitter
followings running into millions.
Those who believe in concepts like
the caliphate and the apocalypse
so much of the Daesh propaganda
stretched deep into parts
of Muslim societies and the belief
in innate hostility between Islam
and the West is unfortunately
not the preserve of a few.
More than that every day millions
of young people are taught a view
of the world in religion
completely incompatible
with peaceful coexistence.
As with for example some of
the Madrassas in Pakistan
or the Almijiri schools in
northern Nigeria, indoctrination
of children is happening
on a daily basis.
Even in countries like my own a
recent documentary in the UK showed
that there are community
centers, mosques,
seemingly innocuous
charity organizations,
that are effective
fronts for this ideology.
My foundation Center on Religion
and Geopolitics tracks
this extremism day by day.
You can see the results
on our website.
It's fascinating but alarming.
So this ideology has
deep roots and we have
to reach right the
way down to uproot it.
We need for example in a similar way
to the campaign on the environment
to agree what I've called an
international global commitment
on education where it is part of
each nation's global responsibility
to promote culture and religious
tolerance and to eradicate culture
and religious prejudice within
their education systems,
formal or informal.
Again it is not acceptable
for governments
to support extremist groups whether
violent or not and where hostility
and hatred towards others is being
promulgated whether in mosques
or community centers it has
to be exposed to and stopped.
Fourth, on the positive side we
have actively to support those
who are confronting the religious
doctrines of the extremists.
There are in fact now many brave
and serious theologians like those
from the Al Azhar Mosque
in Cairo, renowned clerics
like Shaikh Abdallah Bin Bayyah, who
are showing how the true teaching
of Islam leads to peace and
reconciliation with the modern world
but they need the weight
of a concerted international
effort behind them.
We have to organize the use of the
internet to disseminate messages
of peaceful coexistence and hope
but we have to do it at scale
and we have to build the alliance
between Judeo-Christian civilization
and those within Islam who
are prepared to lead the fight
against the [inaudible] of their
faith and the extremism that goes
with it but again we have to do this
with urgency and heft and we have
to organize ourselves
to do it effectively.
Fifth, we sometimes look at the
Middle East and we see such a mess
that we prefer to stay out.
The attacks in Paris as if we needed
further reminding shows the futility
of that.
The Middle East's harsh and
tumultuous transition is our affair
because it is near to
us certainly in Europe,
because it is where the
heart of Islam beats,
because we have our own
large Muslim populations,
because we have allies not only
Israel but Arab nations too
who expect and deserve our support
and whose support in turn we need
to succeed and because
if we don't act then
into the vacuum will step
those whose interests
and values may be opposed
to our own.
In my view it is better to see
the Middle East and indeed Islam
as in a long process of
transition, the Middle East
to achieve rule-based economies
and religiously tolerant societies
and Islam to recover its
rightful place as a faith
of progress and humanity.
Looked at in this way the Middle
East is not an impenetrable mess
to stay clear of but a
life-and-death struggle
in which our own interests
are intimately engaged
so across the region we
should be supporting those
who are fighting back
against the extremism.
In each case we should be promoting
those who will work for a modern
and open-minded future for
the Middle East and for Islam.
For the Gulf states Egypt and
Jordan these are our allies
and where our allies have
their own challenges of change
and modernization to go through
we should be helping them actively
to evolve in order to avoid the
destabilization of revolution
and whether our groups or nations
who are trying to impose or export
and ideology of extremism as
with Sunni extremist groups
of various varieties
or Shia as with Iran
and Hezbollah we should be
again actively constraining
and opposing their influence
and we should not lose sight
of the continuing crucial importance
of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict important in its own right,
important for what a resolution
of it means for the principle
of peaceful existence and important
also because it stands in the way
of the obvious convergence
of interest
between Israel and the Arab nations.
In short we should learn the lessons
of the whole period from 9/11
to today and try to forge a
new synthesis of foreign-policy
which recognizes the need for
an active policy of engagement
but in a way sophisticated by our
experience not incapacitated by it.
For Europe there is a huge
calculation to be made.
This security threat is at our door.
It is actually within our home.
We have a paramount
interest in defeating it
which is why last night's
vote in the British House
of Commons was so important.
Europe has to create within its
nation states the armed force
capability to allow us not just to
play our part but where necessary
to lead and we have to educate our
own citizens and those now coming
into our countries on what our
values and our way of life mean,
why they matter to us and why
we will defend them to the last.
So we need that comprehensive
strategy
with all these different
elements brought together.
Elements that aren't just about
military power but are also going
to the roots of the
extremist ideology
that gives rise to the violence.
But let me end on a
note of optimism.
This is a battle we will win.
There is no doubt in
my mind of that.
From one corner of the world to
another the overwhelming majority
of people whatever their faith
want to live in harmony and peace.
The Islamists fanatics will never
kill the spirit of civilization.
They will be defeated and we
will endure of that I'm sure.
But to defeat this
fanaticism and the ideology
that accompanies it
would require leadership,
vision and a determination that
only full measures will do.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much
Tony, that was,
how shall I say it,
fascinating [laughter].
>> Well I'm glad I fascinated you.
>> Fascinating because as coherent
and compelling the strategy
that you presented is there's a gap
between the very [inaudible]
argument that you make
about what needs to be done and
the will in the United States
and the capacity in
Europe to actually do it.
So how do you actually
bridge that gap
if you agree that that gap exists?
>> I mean I think it is the same
challenge here in my country
or in Europe and the
first thing you've got
to ask yourself is how
serious is this problem
and are we exaggerating it, are we
making it more than it really is?
And that then, the onset
of that then obviously implies the
measures you have to take, mind you
and I spent a large time in office
dealing with this issue post 9/11.
I've spent the largest
part of my life
since leaving office
looking at it, studying it.
I think this is a big problem.
I think it's fundamental and
it threatens our security
in a profound way so if you
think that then you have
to do what is necessary and
I think if we get our heads
into a slightly different
place and look at this
as a long-term generational
struggle, I mean similar
to the struggle we faced against
revolutionary communism if you want
to put it like this, there will
be many different phases of it,
you will have to attack the
problem in many different ways
but in the end if you believe
it is really life-threatening
for your country and for its
stability you have to be prepared
to do what it takes and
I think it's that bridge
that people find difficult for
reasons I completely understand.
In the aftermath of 9/11 people felt
this is the issue we have to tackle
but then in the distance with time
people realize it's very tough
and I know this having gone
through Afghanistan and Iraq to deal
with the problem, but I think if we
look from 9/11 to the present day
when we've tried intervening it's
been difficult, when we stayed
out it's been difficult,
when we partially intervene
it's been difficult.
Now there are two alternative
conclusions from that.
One is that we're just
not very good at our jobs
and the other is it's tough and
it's going to take a long time
but I think the people in Europe
after Paris I think
the mood has changed.
>> One part of this
gap that I'm pointing
to here is a definitional one.
You define the problem
as Islamist extremism.
In Washington it's
called violent extremism
and there's an unwillingness
to label it in the way
that you have essentially
because of the belief
that this will make it harder to get
the Muslim world behind the effort
to deal with the extremists.
How do you answer that?
>> I completely understand that
and indeed I went through a period
when this was all first happening
when I tended to that view
and obviously building an alliance
with people within Islam is central
to defeating this challenge
for sure, but one of the things
that I discovered in
politics is if you go too far
from what a nonpolitical person
of reasonable intelligence
would think is fair
and clear then you don't end up
dealing with the problems you face
so I don't think that it disables
us in achieving the alliance
within Islam to call it Islamist
extremism because that is what it is
and you can't divorce, I mean do
they represent the proper faith
of Islam?
No. But are they doing what they
are doing by reference to religion?
Well they are.
I remember when I was
dealing with the peace process
in Northern Ireland and having
a conversation with people
where they said to me in all
this business between Protestants
and the Catholics there's nothing
really to do with religion.
And I said well that's
a pity because they seem
to think it is [laughter].
So I get this completely and I also
understand why it's important you
don't also stigmatize people's views
because not all Islamists
are violent
but here's what I've come
to think studying this.
When Boko Haram kidnapped
girls and treat them
as in effect sexual slaves
I think that is connected
to a much broader feeling within
for example the Muslim brotherhood
which sees women as
second-class citizens.
So I think if you have an ideology
that says the West is
fundamentally opposed to Islam
and its values are a threat
to us and our belief system,
if that's what you believe in large
number you will get a small number
of people who say well if we
are humiliated by the West
in this way we should fight back.
So my point is until you destroy
the narrative that underpins this,
okay we could defeat ISIS
but we'll have someone else.
>> So that goes to one
part of your strategy
which is the ideological
battle and you laid
out a few points, elements of this.
I know in your article you go
into greater detail but part
of it requires mobilizing
Muslim preachers
against the Muslim preachers
that are preaching extremism
and you cited the head of the Al
Azhar Mosque in Egypt as one example
of that but I think
we have the impression
that those voices are
pretty thin and small
and there is an apparent -,
it appears that there is an
unwillingness amongst Muslim
religious leaders to actually
speak out clearly and continuously
against the kind of extremism that
you speak of so is it realistic
to expect them to mobilize
and how are we going to do it
because it doesn't seem
very successful so far.
>> It's changing.
And remember in all of these
countries they've now got a
problem themselves.
I mean the big difference and
possibly opportunity for us
in this situation is that in each of
the countries, and the countries you
and I know are well
out in the Middle East,
they've all got their own
internal problems today.
This is their problem.
And I think for a long period of
time political leadership certainly
in the Middle East but
also elsewhere was content
to channel some of the political
energy for change often to this kind
of Islamist ideology, but now
it's a big problem for them
and you see I think one
of the first ways you deal
with a problem is get it out on the
table, just make clear what it is
that you're dealing with, so I would
say I can see a lot of evidence,
I would say quite a
lot of evidence now,
that people are getting prepared
to mobilize and they are prepared
to fight back and in the end you saw
maybe the leading [inaudible] Muslim
organization the other day which is
got 50 million members issued what
was not just a call to reject
violence and jihadism and extremism
but was a theological justification
of why modernizing
Islam was sensible.
So this is important.
I feel this is -- , you see one of
the things that I think we've got
to do in the West as we've got
to organize with our allies.
When you take the amount of stuff
that's out there on the Internet
from the jihadists, okay we can go
and pressure the internet companies
to take it down and so
on, but we're fighting
against the tide the
whole time but we need
to be mobilizing those people who
are going to put different images
and metaphors and analogies out
there and there are such people
so I'm not pessimistic about it,
I just think if we think
this threat is as serious
as I think it is then we
need to get a different level
of organization commitment.
>> Let's talk about ISIS.
Part of your strategy is to destroy
ISIS, not to defeat and degrade
but to actually destroy it,
but I sense that you kind
of pulled your punch there by
saying well it shouldn't be boots
on the ground or we should
play a supportive role.
Don't we really need boots
on the ground to do the job
that you think is so important here?
>> You're going to have to have
full [inaudible] on the ground.
I mean I personally think -- , I
know we already are by the way,
we are moving from a position
where we're merely supporting
to actually doing more
active engagement.
I think -- , let me put it in --
, and I'm choosing my
words very carefully
because we've just got authority in
the U.K. yesterday to do airstrikes.
There's not an appetite I would
say in the U.K. or probably here
for force capability on the
ground but we need to consider --
, if it is important
to destroy them we need
to decide what it takes to do that.
Now there are people by the way,
again allies that we can work with,
but they're going to need a
lot of support and help from us
and there is no way with
this so-called caliphate
that you can think of it as
being constrained in some way.
I mean the training
camps of Al Qaeda
in Afghanistan before 9/11 were
on a much more restricted basis
than these are now and so
I mean again it depends
on how serious you think the threat
is but I don't think you can allow
that large part of territory
to be used as a training camp
for terrorism and we've
got, you know obviously
from Europe we've got thousands
of our own people going there
and they come back and
they're our citizens
and I think also destroying
the concept of the caliphate
as represented by ISIS is
also very important, so -
>> There's one country in
the region, a NATO ally right
on the border of Syria, that
probably is the only country
with an army capable of
providing the troops on the ground
that could do the job with
our support and that's Turkey,
but Turkey seems to prefer to fight
the Kurds than they do to fight ISIS
so are they critical
to this strategy
and if they are how do
you get them to step up?
>> They are critical to
it and I actually sat
with President [inaudible] a
couple of weeks ago in [inaudible].
I mean I think they have
their own real concerns
around the Kurdish issue which are
understandable whatever view you
take of the future but they also do
understand now they've got a major
problem with Isis and as [inaudible]
explain to me they have two
and a half million refugees
themselves and so if they don't --
, you know one of the complexities
of these situations is people deal
with multiple problems at the same
time but I think it is possible
and I know the U.S. government at
the moment is working very hard
to do this, it is possible to
get the right type of alliance
with Turkey that will
help us in this
and I think there is a case
again for a safe haven or enclave
from which the opposition can
be secure and which can help
with the refugee problem
and that's important
because we need the leverage
of the negotiating table
for the eventual solution in
Syria and that will be the --
, I mean the Vienna process is going
to be incredibly difficult to do
but there will be no acceptable
outcome that leaves Assad there
for anything other than
a transitional period
and the Turks understand that.
As you know [inaudible] and
Assad were once very close.
Now there's obviously a complete
breach so we will need Turkey.
>> You'll need them to
protect the safe haven too.
You're going to have troops
for that purpose as well.
>> We will need that to happen but
you see here's the thing with Syria
that we've watched
over these last years.
As we thought it would
resolve itself and it hasn't
and now you've got a situation
particularly with Russia coming in
and obviously Iran, Hezbollah on the
ground is what made the difference
and propped up Assad
and then when it looked
as if he was crumbling again
than the Russians have come
in to support him but you think of
the refugee crisis we've got arising
out of it and the numbers of people
that have died, the disintegration
of the country and at each stage
we have thought there's a way
that we could just stay out
of it but certainly in Europe
and maybe this looks different here
but in Europe today we
are facing a situation
where Germany may be taking
what a million or more refugees.
As I say you talk to
the Greek Prime Minister
and he's got 700,000 people
waiting for clearance.
How are we going to be able
to do that effectively and so
of course it would be inhumane
to refuse people sanctuary who've
suffered so much but I think this --
, I don't think we've even
begun to understand the nature
of the challenge this is
going to pose for us in Europe
so my view is however difficult
it is the alternative is worse
and I think one of the problems
you get to in situations
like this is you come to a
moment whether as a choice
but on either side it's ugly.
So this is where I think we are.
>> So let's focus on
Europe for a moment.
There's this huge challenge
from the refugees
and that refugee flow could
increase quite dramatically.
That comes on top of the whole
problem of economic stagnation,
the challenge to the euro, the
issue of [inaudible] and the Greeks,
now we've got the potential
for a British exit.
So if you put that all together it
looks from an American point of view
like Europe, the European
experiment is in trouble.
How deep is that trouble?
>> Personally I think the
basic rationale for Europe is
as strong today as it's ever been
in a world where China will be
as powerful, more powerful
than it is today,
India with over a billion people,
a country like Indonesia population
three times that of Germany.
You know for European
nations to keep influence
in the world they need to come
together so the rationale for Europe
after the second World War was peace
and today it's power and I think
that basic rationale is still
there and it holds good.
Europe's got two problems though.
The first is that the single
currency was a policy motivated
by politics but expressed
in economics
and it's caused huge difficulty
for the members of the euro zone
and stagnation of the
European economy.
Secondly, Europe is
close to the epicenter
of all this radical Islamist
mess and we are not --
, our Armed Forces aren't
really geared up to deal with it
so I think this is a
big challenge for Europe
and it can go one of two ways.
You will either get what I
would call a muscular center,
ground that seizes the initiative,
in economic terms realizes you've
got to stimulate the economy
and do structural reform, in other
words not choose between austerity
and reform but combine a
stimulus of the economy and growth
with the structural form Europe
needs and gives itself up,
in a way I have to say that I think
President Hollande is doing quite
effectively for France, gears itself
up to take this threat seriously
but if they don't do that,
if that center does not exert itself
I think there is a real danger
in Europe of a resurgent nationalism
that could be very dangerous
for the European experiment.
>> Are you worried
about British vote?
>> Yes, I'm worried because
there is a vote [laughing]
and I think Britain
will vote to stay in
but people sometimes ask me here
is it possible that Britain votes
to leave which I'll say
well it's certainly possible
because there's a referendum
and the opinion polls
at the moment are pretty
50-50 and the other thing
if this refugee crisis
is not handled
in the right way then I think
you could have a situation
in which anti-European
feeling in the U.K. is stronger
so in my view it's not
sensible in the end.
I think the interests of Britain
are hugely in favor of staying
and I think that's David
Cameron's instinct as well
but it's definitely a risk.
>> We're going to go to audience
questions in a moment but I have
to ask you my last question
which is about the issue that you
and I worked on so hard for so
long, the Israeli-Palestinian issue.
You were of course
the quartet envoy,
I was for a while there
the U.S. envoy.
The situation has gone
from bad to worse to worse.
We now have a low level
[inaudible] of the knives,
a right-winged government in Israel
that is moving if anything further
to the right and further away
from the two state solution
that we were trying to promote.
What do you think needs
to be done there?
What do you think can
be done there now?
>> Well you've got a
lighter scent of this than me
because you were [laughter]
in a shorter period of time
and by the way I hope you
understand that the work you did was
of fundamental importance and will
stand the test of time in the end.
Whatever solution they come back to
will be very much based on the work
that you and John Kerry did in my
view because ultimately my view
of this matter is ultimately
if the issue were a simple
negotiation it would be tough
but doable.
The idea you can't find an
answer to the border question
or security, of course you can.
If you want to find an answer
to these problems you can
find an answer to them.
Even Jerusalem by the
way I think you can.
So the problem is the context
in which this is happening
and my view it is very
simply because otherwise you
and I both could talk for
several days on this topic.
My view very simply is that the key
to reviving the peace
process lies in the region.
I don't think Palestinian politics
is strong enough at the moment
to carry the process and I don't
think Israeli politics is strong
enough to carry the process but
I think both could be helped
with guidance from
America obviously.
The Arab nations decided that
this was a priority for them
to help revive the peace process
and assist in resolving these issues
and I do think you need the economic
security and the political all
to go together but
then you know that.
>> But I mean we've
come full circle.
It all comes down -- , what you're
saying is it all comes down,
all of these problems come
down to the Sunni Arab
states and their leaders.
>> Well it comes down to a basic
issue of cultural acceptance.
I mean I really do believe that.
What globalization does is it throws
the world closer together and what
that means is if you have a
closed-minded attitude towards the
world in that process of
integration you're seeing a threat
and you're fighting against that and
you think that this moving together
of the world is somehow threatening
your belief system or your way
of life or your community
and the alternative view is
to say look this is
a great opportunity
but the reason quite apart
from everything else why I think
the Israeli-Palestinian issue is
important is what a symbol of
peaceful coexistence it would be
if you could solve
it but it requires --
, there's a deep cultural division
that needs to be overcome their
and I do think these things are
all in the end linked together
but the one thing I would say
about the world today arising
out of the conflicts in the
Middle East is that it's in flux
and usually when things are
in flux there's an opportunity
to shape things so this is
why I think we need to be kind
of imaginative and creative enough
to build an alliance with those
within Islam who share
the understanding
that in the end you've got
to open your mind to others
and that actually trying to
run countries by reference
to religion is not
a -- , you can't do
that in today's multi-faith world.
You've got to be religiously
tolerant.
If you're not religiously tolerant
as a society you're
going to go nowhere.
You look at the successful
countries in the world.
They're all countries that
are open to the world.
Those that shut down in the face
of it they go nowhere so this is
where I think the situation
is and in the Middle East.
You've got this politics that
has been disfigured and deformed
over a long period of time, you've
got these young populations.
I mean a country like
Egypt is 90 million today.
50 years ago, 60 years
ago it was 30 million.
You know the average age
in Gaza was about 19.
One quarter of the population
is under the age of five.
You've got these young
populations, this deformed politics
and then you throw
into this religion
and particularly very dogmatic
view of religion, well -
>> It's a potent brew.
>> Yes it is.
>> Let's go to some
audience questions.
>> The first question is can Islamic
extremism be effectively fought
without a commitment to
a new spirit of openness
and democracy in Arab nations?
>> I think ultimately you
certainly do need that spirit.
You at least need an acceptance
that society should be religiously
tolerant so you can argue
about democracy certainly in
relation to some of the Gulf states
but an open mind certainly there
is no way out of that I don't think
and I think this is where we've also
got to recover our own confidence
and our own belief system.
I mean I think -- , it's interesting
I was in Congress earlier today
and talking to several members
of Congress and I was interested
in the sense that people --
, I think it's quite important for
America to understand sometimes
that even though people will be very
critical of America underneath all
of that there is also an
admiration and I will say
to people it's a great test of a
country, are people trying to get
into it or out of it [laughing].
I mean basically I think your
problem is immigration as it is
in ours so I think -- , I mean maybe
I'm completely wrong about this
and far too sort of utopian about
it, but I actually think most people
if they are given the choice would
prefer to be living in a spirit
of open-mindedness with other people
and I find even in the most --
, you know the countries, even
in the countries where all
of this Islamic stuff is most
rife I still believe a majority
of people would be
perfectly happy in coexistence
but this is always the way that
the extremes can create the tension
through violence that
divides the community
but yes I think a spirit
certainly of the open mind
and in the end I think of
democracy as necessary.
>> The next question is about
both the United Nations and NATO
and what roles they each
may play in this conflict.
>> I don't know, I think it's very
hard for the United Nations to --
, one of the things I'm saying today
is we need to get organized and one
of the things I found
when I was Prime Minister
but I think it's even
more true today
which is probably why the G20 was
created is that United Nations is --
, it's hard to get it to
focus down and implement
so it's obviously important
as an authoritative body
because it assembles
all the world's nations
but if you wanted something done
[laughter] you wouldn't necessarily
go there first [laughter] and
that's why I think on this
for example you need something that
is somewhat more ad hoc and informal
and that's why I'm suggesting --
, the UN for example actually does
have a good counter extremism unit
but most countries don't operate
through it and I feel there needs
to be a lot more organization in
this and then I think when you come
to the armed force capability part
of it you also need to do that
and NATO alone is not -- ,
that's not what NATO was created
for so it's difficult and I think
you need again to look at how
for example Europe definitely
needs to up its defense capability.
The fact that the U.K. has now
recommitted to minimum 2% of GDP
on defense is good but other
countries need to commit
but also it's not just the fact
you've got the armed force you've
got to have the combat
capability and what is necessary
to fight this new asymmetric
type of warfare.
I think the Gulf states are already
looking at how they come together
and of course they're fighting
this big battle, the Saudis
and [inaudible] in Yemen and then
we need American leadership always
so I think NATO has a role to
play in that but I'm not sure
that NATO institutionally is
capable of doing it so I feel
that right now given the
urgency of this we need to look
for different ways of assembling
the right coalition of purpose.
>> It struck me though that NATO
could play a role in your strategy
of safe havens and no-fly
zones building on the fact
that Turkey is a NATO country.
If you can't get UN Security Council
cover then a NATO cover could
actually be quite useful if
you could persuade Turkey
to play the role that you
want it to play on the ground.
NATO basically maintaining
the no-fly zone.
The UN side of it relates to a
question I had about the aftermath.
It's a question that President
Obama asks his aides all the time
which is okay let's say we go
in there and defeat them again.
Who's going to do the
job afterwards?
Who's going to fill that vacuum?
We saw what happened in Libya.
There is a fundamental problem
of collapse of institutions
and how do you rebuild the
institutions and who does that
and couldn't the UN actually
play an important role there?
>> I mean we went through this
in Afghanistan and Iraq obviously
and then Libya now and one of
the problems is it's not just
about rebuilding institutions
often it's about creating them
because so-called strong men were
often in charge of weak states
because of the way that they were
run and I think change today I think
that would allow us to do this
better is a) we've got experience,
b) we have allies and
c) we now understand
that without the security
element being
in the correct place it's
impossible to do anything else.
I mean my instinct about this is
though is that we've got to --
, this is why I say we've got to
look upon this in a different way.
If we are expecting a quick
result and a clean sort
of okay now that's done, I
think we are kidding ourselves
but I think sustained
engagement over a period
of time though difficult is
preferable to a vacuum that is going
to be filled by either extremists
or other interests and powers
that may have an agenda
completely contrary to our own
and therefore I suppose what I
think ultimately is the difficulty
of doing it is not as great as the
danger of not doing it but I say
to people all the time
this is really difficult.
>> Yes, and Americans listening
to you I think a lot would say
we did that, we went in there
and we tried to rebuild Iraq and
we tried to rebuild Afghanistan
and we spent a huge amount of
American blood and British blood
and treasure, trillions of
dollars, and it didn't work
so why do you think it
can work this time around?
Just because we know
better how to do it?
>> I think partly but I think
also because you've always got
to ask the question,
the counterfactual,
so I mean leave aside Iraq
from being more controversial
in this sentence but if you look
at Afghanistan it would really
be better if we had done nothing
or if we hadn't tried
to do that building.
You see when we were fighting
the Cold War and if you'd said
to somebody in the 70s or 80s well
you're spending all this money
fighting the Cold War
but you would've said well I'm
afraid were going to do it and I --
, it all depends how you
identify the problem.
If the problem is violent
extremism, a group of fanatics,
then you're probably right.
>> You try to contain it.
>> Yes, but if it isn't
and it's broader
than that then I think you do have
to try and defeat it completely
and so I think so much of
the policy consequence flows
from that initial analysis.
I always say to people I've
approach to this with huge humility
and I think it's a poor [inaudible]
to get into who is responsible
for this or that or whatever but
I think we've got to try in a way
to say well what really
have we learned from 2001?
Now if we've decided we've
learned is we should stay
out of everything I would
argue that Syria shows you
that that's not a great strategy
either and maybe what we can do,
and this is what I was
arguing in my remarks,
is you can actually synthesize
those two periods of policymaking
and construct a policy of active
engagement with allies that is
as I said sophisticated by our
experience and not incapacitated
by it but I can't see myself that
we've got an option in the end
and by the way we've talked
a lot about the Middle East
but in my view the single
biggest threat sub-Saharan Africa
in development terms today
could be this extremism.
In countries like Kenya I mean this
is absolutely existential for them.
You have a country like
Somalia or Mali or [inaudible]
in northern Nigeria, now you
look at how we deal with that
but you've already got now almost
three million people displaced
in northern Nigeria so I think
one of the things I also say
to Europeans is we've got to look
at our own responsibilities here
because you guys are a long
way away from all this.
Now you're still America so you're
still the big power and we need you
but you know we in Europe why
if you've got these Syrian
refugees how could we say no
to the refugees coming
from northern Africa
or the northern part
of sub-Saharan Africa?
>> Do you have another question?
>> We have time for two more.
The first is actually a
question about Lebanon,
it's role in the conflict
and the probability
of violence there reigniting.
>> I think people are right to
be very worried about Lebanon
and it's a tragedy for the
country, it's a great country,
fantastic people but you know
it's the same issue isn't it?
They are kept in a permanent state
of destabilization by Hezbollah
and Iran and that's why I
think one of the things we have
to do is we have to be pushing back
against that power very strongly.
But if Lebanon were completely
to destabilize it would
have a serious impact
on the whole region
including obviously on Israel.
>> You know it's interesting
that this is the first time
that Iran has entered
into our discussion
which would not have been the case I
think before the Iran nuclear deal.
It's kind of taken the wind out
of their argument in a strange way
but is Iran part of the problem or
part of the solution when it comes
to the broader Middle East?
>> Well at the moment for the region
as a whole it's a destabilizing
influence.
Now can they be persuaded or
can there be change within Iran
that allows those people who
obviously have a different
and more moderate view,
can we get to a stage
where that strain of
thinking prevails?
I don't know.
I hope so.
But if you look at the activities of
Iran and whether in Lebanon or Syria
or Yemen or the attempts to
destabilize the Gulf states,
even attempts to get support within
Hamas, I mean I find it hard to look
at Iran's influence in the
region and see it positively.
>> Last question.
>> The final question is on Northern
Ireland and the peace process
and whether there are parallels
or lessons from your experience
that could be applied
to the Middle East.
>> There are some but
we were very fortunate
in the Northern Ireland
process of having leadership
on virtually every side that really
wanted to do things and was prepared
to be quite brave with
their end support.
David Trimble with [inaudible],
Jerry Adams [inaudible],
[inaudible] the Irish
prime minister [inaudible].
You know we had a good constellation
of leaders at that time
but there are certain lessons.
I mean one is that you have to
get a framework that is fair.
The second is you will spend
long time implementing it.
The third is never to
give up and I still think
in the Middle East peace
process we should never give up.
I fear that personal
consequences of carrying on my head
against that brick wall
but the other great factor
in Northern Ireland was the
spirit of the Irish obviously
and I remember what we used
to do in Northern Ireland is
when we hit a logjam in a
negotiation we'd take the Irish
and the different parties all the
way for a sort of weekend kind
of brainstorm and get
everyone back on track again -
>> Get everybody drunk [laughter]?
>> Right, I was putting that
more diplomatically [laughter],
but I remember there
was an occasion in 1999
when my wife was then pregnant
with our child who was born
on Downing Street and
during the course of one
of these weekends away
one of the delegation
from Northern Ireland came up to me
and said congratulations Prime
Minister, it's a wonderful thing,
you know your wife
is expecting a baby
and he said what do you
think you will call it?
And I said well I don't know I think
if it's a boy I think I'll
call it after my father, Leo.
And he said oh that's a lovely
thought, that's a lovely thought.
Anyway, my wife gave birth,
we were away a month later
and I saw this guy again and
he had a fantastic suntan.
Now I don't know whether you've
ever been to Northern Ireland
but [laughter], there's many great
things about Northern Ireland
but you're not liable to come
away with a suntan so I said
to him my God you look fantastic,
where did you get that suntan from?
And he said well actually
you're responsible for.
I said I'm responsible for it?
He said yes remember that
conversation I had when I asked
about your wife being
pregnant and I asked
about what you might call the child?
And I said yes.
He said well the next day I
went down to the bookmakers
and put 1000 pounds on
the name of the child -
[ Laughter ]
So that was another major reason
why it succeeded [laughter].
>> Ladies and gentlemen I think we
should thank Tony Blair very much
for a fascinating conversation.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.